Знайомтеся, це - Нетта з Ізраїлю.
Зі своєю піснею "Toy" - "Іграшка"- вона вважається
головною фавориткою цьогорічного Євробачення.
25-річна виконавиця вдало комбінує легку музику з важкою темою.
Моя пісня - це серйозний меседж в контексті кампанії MeToo.
Я шукала якесь фанкове звучання для приспіву,
щоб це звучало як домагання, ось так...
Чи як захист.
Це ніби й весела після, але з дуже сильним меседжем.
Під час офіційного відкриття "Євробачення" 6 травня
журналісти та фани мали нагоду познайомитися з учасниками.
Дехто вже понад тиждень проводить репетиції на сцені в Лісабоні.
Загалом - представники 43 країн.
Дев'ять років тому він уже виграв "Євробачення" - Олександр Рибак з Норвегії.
І хоч кажуть: двічі в одну річку не ввійдеш, Рибак цьогорiч знову серед фаворитів.
Утім, спланувати перемогу на "Євробаченні" неможливо.
Він знає це, як ніхто інший. Ян Феддерсен уже понад 25 років
коментує "Євробачення" і написав про конкурс книгу.
Пісня-переможець мусить мати якусь хімію, зокрема її виконання.
Це означає, публіка має відчути співачок та співаків,
наскільки сильно вони кайфують від свого виконання.
Просто вийти і виконати номер - недостатньо.
Цей рок-гурт з Угорщини готовий викластися на повну.
Данець Расмусен робить ставку на автентику вікінгового стилю.
Грузія представлена етно-джазом
з традиційним поліфонічним хоровим співом від гурту "Iriao".
Еліна Нечаєва з Естонії робить ставку виключно на голос.
Вона - професійна оперна співачка.
Я співаю від душі, від серця. І сподіваюся, що
мій меседж про силу кохання дійде до сердець глядачів.
Серця глядачів хоче завоювати також німець Міхаель Шульте.
Свою пісню він присвятив померлому батькові.
Ще один цьогорічний фаворит - Франція.
У пісні дуету "Madame Monsieur" йдеться про дівчинку, яка народилася на човні біженців.
Історія реальна.
Це дуже важлива та зворушлива історія.
Ми довідалися про це з Твіттера і захотіли написати
про це пісню, щоб люди відчули те ж, що й ми.
За Болгарію цього року виступає проект "Equinox",
в якому об'єдналися найуспішніші музиканти країни.
Вони вважають це символічним для такого конкурсу, як "Євробачення".
Ми всі абсолютно різні і ми святкуємо це.
Просто уявіть собі світ, де люди справді святкують те, що вони різні!
І останній з фаворитів - чех Міколаш Йозеф.
Він актор і модель, але своїм покликанням вважає музику.
Співаючий Ді Капріо хоче насамперед розважити фанів "Євробачення".